In this case study, we're
going to quickly look
at how an image
of your apparatus
could become an interesting
photograph to submit
for a cover or used as a figure.
Here, we're
suggesting a process.
Now, because I couldn't
photograph the experiment
as it was going on, because
it was a closed system,
I made an initial image of the
apparatus used in the research.
These wires are
heated to vaporize
polymer material, which is
then deposited onto chips,
as you see here.
I first thought it would make
a nice image for a cover,
leaving room for
the journal's logo.
As it turned out, that image
was used for the MIT News page.
I then decided to add another
piece of their apparatus
to fill the whole image.
In the end, we did submit
this one for the cover,
but it didn't get it.
What we did get was something
called the frontispiece
in the journal.
And surprisingly, they
preferred this inverted image,
which I made just for fun,
rather than the original.
Frankly, I personally
preferred the first one,
but you just never
know people's taste.